this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be with you we
sincerely want the best for everybody
and the best thing that we can offer is
not a Ferrari or say a Mercedes van or a
Bentley or even the biggest house but
it's this invitation that will bring you
peace peace first and foremost with the
one who created you the one who created
all that is this the same God that Jesus
peace be upon him worship the one God
and all the messengers of God they
brought the same message submit your
entire self to the one creator and this
is how you can have peace now this
beautiful way of life it's not because
Islam means peace acquired by submitting
your entire self to the one who created
you there are a lot of misconceptions
Islam yes is the fastest one way of life
in the world today but it's the most
misunderstood people say it's a barbaric
religion you'll see some politicians who
are supposed to be bringing people
together they're out here quoting the
verbatim Word of God out of context can
you believe it so today we're gonna have
someone who's knowledgeable in slump a
person that these people should be going
to if they have some confusion about
Islam because that's how we can truly
live together cooperate together and
build bridges together and that's what
we should be doing and that's what we're
gonna be doing today clearing up the fog
clearing out the junk from the trunk and
helping you is slant understand this
beautiful way of Islam a little bit
better sit tight don't go Noble be right
back
so I'm like Oh peace be unto you say cuz
that I got ready what do you got there
man let's see what can happen you have
this management done that now when you
cut off the the hand of the the thief is
it like that or is it like this well
I'll tell you it's that important how to
but it what's important is what people
think of it now this is the thing now
you know all jokes aside you know it's a
very important topic that we're trying
to cover but you know what some people
make a mockery of this beautiful way of
life the way of life that's from the
Creator that happens on earth so we want
to clear up the many misconceptions you
know Islam is about mercy
you know Islam is a merciful religion
but some would try to have people think
that it's the antithesis that's it Abba
bark way of life and we're gonna start
off with explaining in context people
say you know what Islam is just about
chopping the head chopping the hands and
then you got chopped up meat to eat so
let's talk about this is that what Islam
is all about chopping people up
absolutely not
as a matter of fact on the contrary God
Almighty actually tells us how to
prevent this from happening by the Torah
he buna meaning that it's I'd fear it to
them why to prevent them from fighting
to start off with to actually save the
bloodshed to actually do this to give
them options other than having to fight
and believe it or not this is one of the
options when people think that Islam is
barbaric by the cutting the hand they
only see the end result they don't look
at the older root cause analysis look at
the prevention is better than cure
method they look at just that but if you
look deeply you'll find out that Islam
is trying to prevent this from happening
by telling you if you do this
we will do that so it's scaring you off
don't do it and you find out the case is
that Islam looks at a bigger picture the
bigger picture of the community for
example if everyone is protected from
one person meaning the thief it is a way
of life in Islam it is the good of all
proceeds the good of one so you should
be happy about this
but the idea behind it is people only
look for the fish for faults or look for
certain things but under the normal
human beings nature of instinct that
they want some things we all have whims
and desires but we have to control it
there is a checks and balances in these
if you don't have a fear of God Almighty
okay if you don't have the love for God
Almighty the same ideas that we tell you
if you cross the red light we will put
up we slap you with a fine so you there
is something there that love and fear
you have to have that combination of
both not just love with other people
that try to preach it's not the case
human beings have to have both so the
same thing you get rewarded if you don't
do this and if you do this you will get
punished but the idea behind it is that
now we're saving you know this man from
himself not just everybody else same
idea with the bigger context the bigger
picture the community which looks for in
Islam is that prevention is better than
cure
don't do this otherwise you would and
you'll see the statistics in hamdulillah
that is much lower than anybody else as
you will see in Western society you'll
see a repetitive people you know do
certain the crimes when we come back and
plead insanity to come back and do it
again the taxpayers pay the same thing
and you'll see you do the same thing for
the kids they do that and they keep
doing it for that so we say Islam says
no stop
we have consequences to protect everyone
else in the community so can you say
this is a strong deterrent and when this
is implemented and can we just back it
up because we know that Islam the way of
life that was lived by Abraham Moses
Jesus peace be upon him because Islam
calls to surrender and submit to the
creator of heavens and earth not a man
or a monkey but the creator of all that
exists and
as one who does Islam so when this
complete system God's system from the
creditor device and was implemented
isn't it true that there wouldn't be
people who were for instance poor you
have the zakat
they'll be justice so you wouldn't have
all these criminals out here you know
robbing stealing looting could we back
it up to that absolutely this is a one
way to look at what allows upon our
trial app with just a sentence at the
time of our Mohammed alarm is actually
lifted this hook this is this rule was
not it was actually invalid because
there was not enough for people to eat
so we say there are rules and
regulations if everyone has enough for
sustenance and provisions for them to
feed themselves and feed their families
now you're actually going to transgress
on others right so we'd say you know if
you see a beautiful flower
enjoy it you want to smell it great but
do you want to cut it we say no stop
you see that's that when we say now
taking somebody else's freedom you're
teaching you to take the easy way out so
you become you become a thief and so on
this is even saying that even our kebab
went to a man says if you don't give
that man that works for you enough money
to be able to live we will cut your hand
off that's the employer to the bus
correct pay him right absolutely yeah so
we have all these checks of bounds in
order for you to prevent this from
happening and everything is provided for
you and if you're not having a job the
system looks after you and after all
these things that we will look after
you're under circumstances you decide to
go on your own take somebody else's
right and decide to go you will pay the
consequences
it's human nature so is this also more
for the the plotter planner the schemer
the person now who's gonna break in your
home and he knows that you have a
diamond watch he knows that you have a
bankroll in your safe and he puts your
family in jeopardy your children and
your why because if you see him now he
gets the gun out of fear he might kill
you so is this for that person that
broke in your home almost maybe possibly
rape your wife to steal your life
savings is that the person we're talking
about absolutely I mean Islam is justice
established justice upon everything
including criminal
fences for example if we tell someone
that this man that you just talked about
came to your home you know raped your
wife you know took your daughter away it
took your money and and all that if I
tell you what would you do and do this
you would cut him to pieces you would
kill him apart says no Islam is more
merciful than that we will just cut
their hand we will ask him what hand did
you go were cut with and it would be
this hand that we would cut according to
his testimony and of course we
understand that this specific fact that
almond kitab again going back to him
the woman came to ask him to pardon her
son because he stole he was caught
stealing he says well aji by a by god
almighty is not the first time he stole
because god almighty will not have
exposed them from the first time so god
almighty gives you chances and chances
and chances say if we cut early it's
preventative as opposed of you going up
on the ladder being even worse of a
thief under criminal and god almighty
give you too many chances but when you
get caught that means it's better for
you because god almighty says that in
the plan we can give him a taste of
punishment in this life before the taste
of punishment in the hereafter certainly
may come back and if you do it expects
you send if every penalty is done here
in this life as if you've done none
you're clear this is amazing yeah
because that's an important point it's a
very important point like if somebody
just stole your keys to your house or
your cell phone with all your contacts
and then you ask the person right now in
his rage like what would you do this
probe you caught him that's a violation
of your right something private
something that you hold valuable that
person like you said we wanna now you
know have his way if he was the judge
but islam is even more merciful we're
gonna take a break and i got so many
more questions to ask you about this
when we come back here on daddy's show
sit tight i solo on deals that allows
solo yeah na seuk lesson i would go to
my room lock the door prostrate and cry
saying God you know me better than
myself show me the right way and I will
not look I will leave everything behind
a lot of that greater any career
everything just intelligent back here on
the Dean show with Sheikh Allah thank
you very much for being with us Hannity
show pleasure thank you for having me
you have a lot of experience you're the
director of the Islamic Circle Centre of
Canada and also public relations
director for mercy mission so you have a
lot of experience with this with dealing
with these type of questions and we're
trying to create a better understanding
with the not yet Muslims those brothers
that are brothers and humanity is that
right absolutely
now tell us just before we go on to the
next misconception and putting things in
context you know tell me what you think
about this because we know that you know
all these rules and regulations are from
the divine and there's great wisdom
behind any logical person who looks at
it in context who will see this makes
sense so the the criminal he's plotting
and planning and he's putting aside
money he sees the big heist I'll make a
million here but he's putting like five
six seven eight ten thousand dollars a
wafer for the attorney hoping that you
know if I get caught I'll beat the rap
on a technicality I'll go ahead and get
probation so do you think now is this
known that when you know that look this
is the consequence of you breaking in
someone's home robbing a bank that this
is coming on it's getting a putative
you're not going to do this absolutely
it's again something called the STI
strategic defense initiative because
this will happen if you do then that
means don't mess with me is because of
the consequence yield pay because that's
what gamma minus is it he might become
disallow so part of that I says this cos
øz this retribution do taking a penalty
this keeps you alive keep you away of a
good life so the idea behind it is best
for you not against you so if you think
about even the sisters when they start
complaining about you know why cover and
why wear the hijab among the other can
you know misconception that women are
oppressed and we force them to wear the
head [ __ ] and I tell this is to the same
thing you know when you were young that
now you have what it takes you're you
know vivacious voluptuous and beautiful
you have what it takes to flaunt your
your stuff now
you grow old you don't have what it
takes anymore there's a younger the
sister comes in to now being testing
your husband and so on so we say the
same idea we are now protecting others
from you now when you're young but when
you grow old we're protecting you from
everybody else
same idea with the thief we're
protecting not one person we're
protecting everybody else from one and
that's the methodology of the of Islam
to look after the good of all as opposed
to the good of one and the serene
security of the community when God's
system Islam total complete submission
to the one God creator of all that
exists when his system was implemented
through history were there people now
when this was implemented walking around
with chopped off hands no actually the
believe it or not this these things are
very rarely done very rare very rarely
done actually these things that they
have to have witnesses and the witnesses
come and they and they don't say the
same thing they will be also flogged for
this so Islam makes these things are
very strict very tight so not everybody
else can claim that they've done things
that they have to be caught with the
evidence and so on and convicted so
these all these sixes chicks and bounds
to make sure that justice established at
the time of a leap that we thought it
was a matter of fact even though he was
at the head of the state at the time the
college the successor he claimed that
somebody else stole something that
belonged to him that was given to
Prophet by Prophet Muhammad may peace
pond is we know the story but even
though he was a Jew the system defended
the rules and regulations of Islam they
say that do you have any witnesses and
everybody knew that this was his but
they did not see the act nor that was
taken and nobody else's it I have my son
he says you taught us that the branch
will not testify for the root do you
have anybody offices no it says this
belongs to the Jew so the Jewish man
even though he was in the Muslim state
being judged again the head of the state
and the judge was a Muslim he says I
can't believe this in this state the
judge rules with fairness and justice
and he became a Muslim because
slam established justice we're not after
anyone for specific reason so it's not
for a snicker bar you're hungry now and
you need something to feed your family
and you go you know get some food
someone's crop a corn you know some
bread some barley and you're eating out
your hands off absolutely not that's not
about that that's not okay that's really
really deep because when you know that
this is coming off why are you in a
criminal in the first place huh
absolutely yeah so you should be living
a righteous life and this is a deterrent
being content with what you got content
what you got so this is really a strong
deterrent cuz when you know it's coming
out you're gonna stay away from hurting
innocent people and you're gonna stay
away from robbing banks robbing
individuals and it's amazing okay let's
move on this is a very important point
that you hear this a lot now you're also
here and you'll see this again I mean we
want to reach out to the politicians and
I hope that they the Muslims will pass
this on to the politicians they can see
what Muslims are really about because we
have qualified individuals such as
yourself explaining Islam not the car
mechanic or Peter Jing's King or whoever
else is out there that has a twisted
understanding you took years to
understand took years to understand this
Quran the verbatim Word of God
so when people take one verse and
they'll say kill those for instance who
are not Muslims the infidels or what not
you know is this the same thing that
someone who's a terrorist who goes kills
innocent people he'll take a verse to
justify are they doing the same thing to
create division amongst people certainly
one way to do it but before we go on I'd
like to say that this poor slave of
Allah is learning as we are so thank you
for your vote of confidence but we're
all learning is viable first the infidel
the word infidel itself is not really
the proper translation for this catheter
the word catheter that comes in in
different understandings even for a a
peasant like a farmer or something that
covers meaning cover the truth meaning
that the one and only God and so on or
those who disbelieve in the message
doesn't necessarily mean so but the
Quran addresses the Christians in Jews
in a very fair way to say that the
al-khattab oh people of the book and
everybody knows when god almighty says
yeah I like it AB the people of the book
are the Christian and Jews thank you on
that even though they dig under the word
kafir mean disbelieve in the message of
Muhammad may peace be upon him or the
oneness of God it's a different
story but it's not accordingly in photos
but the people when they say that we
have to kill them because the the the
Koran who says that and unfortunately
they do use the cut and paste theory but
if they look before them the look after
it you'll find out the biggest [ __ ] the
context of the whole verse and and we
know that Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
mentioned the quraían ordinary lady
Nadia cattle ooh
it was given permission for those who
being fought those who are being killed
and now a little more they were being
oppressed so what does Islam notices
defend yourself you have the right to
defend yourself
so this says these are the one that
being killed not every thumb they can
hairy and god almighty also reveal these
things with the mushriks of Quraysh
those the idol worshipers that for
everybody those who are killing you they
were driving you out of your home
killing your family stealing your land
taking your worldly possession you have
the right to defend yourself it is not
being an oppressor
aggressive you're being a defensive so
of course that these people say that
because you're not almost like I have to
kill you the amazing thing is that the
Quran gives us permission to marry from
the man to marry from a Christian woman
or a Jewish woman according to the
opinion of some of the scholars under
circumstances can you imagine now my
wife is a Christian or my wife is a
Jewish woman say I love you honey but I
can't be your friend
that's all I can't be friends 6 or I
love you honey but I have to kill you
yeah can you imagine that is absolutely
makes no sense whatsoever so people that
do cut and paste theory they translated
according to their own whims and desires
their own hidden agendas absolutely have
no place in this lab no place in song is
there a verse in the Quran and can you
elaborate on this the translation of the
meaning because we have the Quran as the
verbatim word of god it's tamper free
tamper proof preserved and memorized by
millions that's another topic that it
says that God has not forbid you from
showing kindness to those who have not
fought you or driven you out of your
lands talk to us about it absolutely and
sort of the Montana you go back and
you'll find out the God on - is that
lion have come Allah and Allah dynamic
with the confident of a room with
oxygenating Sevierville verse the
meaning of the interpretation
God Almighty forbids you not to be kind
and just and I'll have to come back to
that word explain it for those who do
not
fight in your religion and do not kick
you out of your home so let us go find
out what the conditions what are the
conditions if people leave Muslims to
worship god almighty and don't kick me
out of your home out of my home and will
have to be more than kind and more than
just I have to go back to the Arabic
word in order for me to translate this
properly and I say at least if you go
just on a parent meaning of the verse if
someone tells you listen I'll leave you
to the worship garden on your the way
you want to worship back and I won't
kick you your home is that too much to
ask that set minimum requirement for any
human being for their own rights so
let's go back to the Arabic text and say
you find out sis is this empty bedroom
the word little in Arabic is it has a
connotation the relationship between
that father a bit the parents and the
children and they were supposed to be
extremely kind to them and Chris the
second one is the Quist is that means
higher than ugly the Arabic word is a
demeaning just unfair but this is
actually higher sometimes is
mistranslated so all we ask is that
being very simple leave us to worship
God in the way that we were so calm and
it to do in the proper way not killing
you or the innocent and so on I've come
back to that if there is a chance and
you do not kick us out of your home our
homes we will treat you more better than
our fathers and mothers and we'll be
more than fair with you not too much to
ask I hope that you're getting to
benefit I surely am and those who are
sincere want to do the truth you come to
the right place a tight form or here on
the deed show we'll find that good clear
out remind in your heart of hatred and
preconceived notions racism and
nationalism
because you cannot have anything inside
of you that's like that against people
and still be successful back here on the
Dean show and we covered the chopping of
the hands we put things in context and
it's not for a snicker par this is for
as a deterrent to keep those people who
are barbaric from hurting the innocent
people any person who has a sound mind
can see that this makes sense so tell us
now we talked about also and continue on
where this misconception of you know oh
we're infidels and you're Muslims and
kill us and all this which by the way
and if you study historically I mean the
Koran is in the Arabic so when you
translate in English just because it's
there it doesn't the author and commit a
made a mistake but this wasn't is true
that this word from studying was coined
actually by the Christian Crusaders who
they called those Muslims infidels who
weren't of the same faith so now it's
being pointed at us and you covered that
that it's not the proper translation so
continue on from there
the part about killing non-muslims okay
and also the friendship between
non-muslims and Muslims absolutely but
first we have to say that we don't blame
everyone for having the misconceptions
yeah because we didn't maybe reach out
or build bridges or educator raise
awareness so all they know about Islam
is love ugh but oh you know they watch a
certain you know news channel or
anything else that they also have their
own head yet hidden agenda and they
don't portray the the proper message out
or they have people that mislead or
misrepresent Islam to be there you know
if it bleeds it leads and their own
whims and desires and having the word
association with it and that's another
topic but now to continue on with what
we're talking about today let's go to
another verse in the quran that allah
subhana wa ta'ala mentioned the quran i
don't have enough time to to go into
everything but at least I mean actually
that accompanies fly eat and know who my
pattern has to provide enough and so on
to the end of the verse in Arabic and
I'm quoting in Arabic because of the
brightness I mean the translation
meaning at the interpretation is
somebody if you kill one innocent soul
as if he killed the whole humanity and
if you kill if you save one innocent
soul as
saved my humanity but the beauty of this
verse again going back to the Arabic
text but who scholar says man potala
naps the word is nurse soul spirit human
being person and it's not that's not
Ellen that's doesn't have Alif LAAM Meem
Alif LAAM meaning it is not definite
it's like he didn't say if you kill a
Muslim soul he didn't he said any soul a
Muslim Christian Jew Buddhist Hindu
agnostic any soul that doesn't even
believe in God is off-limits and that's
what the scholar says government says
any soul as if you kill the whole
humanity that's how severe the
punishment is in the sight of God and if
you save any soul as if you save those
the whole humanity the beauty about it
is that Islam also hold you accountable
for a soul of an animal the prophetic
tradition is authentic when a woman will
be going to the Hellfire not eternally
of course those who believe in one God
well not eternally go to a Hellfire if
they of course repent before they die or
they did not they will pay the price and
come back just to clarify the context
now in the hadith read that because she
tied her did not feed the cat or let her
go out to eat from the systems of God
then she died so we are held accountable
for the spirit or the soul of a cat and
a hadith the prophetic tradition says
the woman or a man booth says that the
acquaints the thirst of a dog they will
be going to heaven for that simple fact
so don't do you think if we're held
accountable for a spirit for a cat or a
dog we will not be held accountable for
the spirit of a human being because the
proof is in the Quran that almighty says
well I've got Quran nobody Adam we have
our weighted or honored or level the
higher in that human being above all you
see so in that essence we have to put
the contract straight so in order for us
to say that you know what I can kill a
human being with no consequences there
is a major consequences even in state of
war the state of war we don't have
anything called collateral damage even
if you kill an innocent person while in
the state of war appla hapa even by
mistake you still have to pay a ransom
there is every human being every soul is
accountable and since we're talking
about wars I'll close with the ten
commandments of war and please compare
the ten commandments of
again no kind of issues in Islam
absolutely and has no competition with
the ten commandments that is known but
this is just of the etiquettes an
immoral conduct of their Muslim army
going to fight and please compare these
ten with what you know about Islam from
any other type of media outlet that this
is the commands from Prophet Muhammad
may peace be on him and his successors
after him he says when he sends an army
to war to defend themselves he says do
not kill a woman do not kill a child do
not kill an old man do not kill an
animal do not cut a tree down do not
pollute the water do not burn their
homes do not invade them at night when
he was asked why you should not invade
them at night he says do so you may not
wake the nurse and mother and child he
says you will see those who devoted
themselves to worship God in their own
ways leave him to worship God in their
own ways as freedom of religion and he
says fight only those who fight you
fight only those who fight you so if you
come in to fight me I fight you if
you're not coming to fight me you're off
the hook
this I mean you know what this has now
been explained in context from the
Muslims from the people who know Islam
so the politicians and those who are out
there I'm sure they're getting a better
understanding too so they can go teach
the rest of the people the truth about
Islam not the things that they messed up
probably on just you know learning from
their own and you know we're not going
to judge their intention but maybe they
had a good intentions they just didn't
know but now they know so tell us now
for someone else who says we got only
got a few more points that you know what
this is when the Muslims were weak
that's why then the Muslims later they
became strong so the rules changed this
was abrogated what you got to say about
that it is amazing because if you go
back in history or find out that when
Muslims were too busy defending
themselves and fighting that propagation
Islam did not flourish Islam only
flourished when was the hood that was
the time that there was no war Islam
multiplied it has got so many and look
at the look at the facts the fact that
that they were when they were fighting
they were very human numbers and when
they had the chance to actually explain
Islam without fighting without the
defense or whatever those who call
people that Islam was spread by the
sword couldn't be further from the truth
but Islam flourished from from human
hundreds the ten thousand when they went
to open and conquest
mekka to get it back how did that happen
with no fighting and that's the truth
and look at the Indonesia is the biggest
Muslim country in the world
there's not one sword that was lifted in
Indonesia and what sword do we have now
and this we know that Islam is the
largest and the fastest-growing religion
on the face of the earth we don't have
any sword so we don't have any the media
and all that's what it takes we simply
don't force you to become a Muslim or
not become a Muslim and then one of the
reasons the scholar says even for the
Muslim armies victorious and we put the
jizya is that proof that there is LOM
gives you a choice to stay on your own
religion and you simply play taxes for
your life to protected we don't force
you let it go have gained no compulsion
religion alone subhana Allah tells
prophet mom Salaam if I wish I would
have made everyone believe in me anta -
korean ask do you would you compose
people to do it and the Slama is very
clear forward to you your way to me my
way we have relayed the message the
truth is clear and the falsehood is also
clear last closing comments or
suggestions also I mean just some more
advice for those who are out there who
they want to do the right thing
published relations people politicians
the average person how can they take
these quranic verses the divine words
from the creator of the heavens on earth
so they don't mess up and take things
out of context what advice do you give
for them in short before we close
don't use the cut and paste theory for
the simple fact is that we can do the
same thing and we certainly know that
that is not the right thing to do so
it's again we welcome you to come and
ask us we actually encourage you to do
so and you will find out that we all
welcome you with open arms and open
hearts so we certainly hope that this is
an open invitation and extend that
helping hand an invitation for a
friendship and hopefully a better
understanding because we simply feel
that ignorant is our number one enemy so
since we eradicate ignorance and people
will not be afraid of what they don't
know
thank you very much may God Almighty the
creator that happens in earth and
everything we say Allah rewards you in
abundance for people to thank you very
much and thank you for sitting tight
through another episode of the Deen show
come back come back every week visit us
and learn more about Islam you got to
hear it put into context you got to hear
it from the Muslims and that's what you
should be doing when you want to know
the truth about Islam
sit with us eat with us go to your local
Masjid go to the houses of worship you
know that Islam calls you to nothing but
good noble behavior righteousness
developing yourself to be the best human
being that you can be and it's built on
the most important fundament that you
worship none but the Creator the heavens
on earth the same God that Jesus Moses
Abraham Noah they all worship the one
God and the last and final messenger the
problem Hamid peace be upon him he came
with the same message he came with the
same message that's to worship one God
do good deeds and be the best human
being that you can be continue to come
back here to dien show to learn more
until next time peace be unto you
you